remember that time when actually no I
don't
hey so you've got a lot to explain in an
elevator ride a feeling prepared are you
feeling scared I'm not afraid of you ha
ha ha ha
maybe you should be because I'm your
limitation I'm the one that you have to
explain everything to no I am not
skipping all right let's get started
ha ha ha so what is memory well let me
think about the brain the brain actually
is consisting of many individual cells
that I think of like little train
stations ok all these train stations are
connected to each other by tracks right
yes so that's the brain cells connecting
to other brain cells by sign APS's so
the tracks are like sign ups and what is
the train so the train is like an
electrical signal ok the neurons like
finding minute video so when we form a
memory we take something from
environment and we put it in one of the
stations yeah and then you know you
recall that memory when you use that
information again yeah so it's kind of
like if you have a really strong memory
yeah then that means the connections
between two stations are really strong
which smarter people have more of those
so what is suppose to happen is that
some people have more stronger
connections between many many stations
and this enables them to I remember
things really quickly yeah and if we
stop using those connections they get
weaker again so how is a memory actually
stored like what physically is it yeah
so there are a lot of theories about
that so what we think if there must be
some full of physical change in the
neurons so like you know something is
happening in this train station because
we know that worms can remember they're
very quite simple animals humans can
remember so something must be
fundamentally changing in this in these
neurons so that's the brain cells which
is not that difficult
right yes so worms don't have action
potentials they don't have myelin which
insulates the signal from being lost but
they can still learn so which implies
that something investigations are
fundamentally similar to humans or other
mammals
we're at the halfway point Oh No JIRA
can you a halfway through explaining
everything that you want to tell me I
think so yes okay good let's go so if
they are stored as some kind of
biochemical and molecular change then if
we figure out what those changes are we
can just kind of put them back in in to
the brains of people who you know have
memory problems or you know near a
degeneration so theoretically if we
could find the physical thing that forms
a memory we could take it out and
Transplant it its theory yes yeah
very very far away from doing that well
how good is the live imaging that we
have with brains it is good but the
resolution is not fantastic we don't
look at like you know individual brain
cells so that's why we use animal models
so I used to worm because they are
transparent I can look at each of their
brain cells individually it's pretty
cool pretty hectic yeah oh that's cool
man so we can figure out what those you
know physical changes are in the warden
and try and translate back to a human so
we take a complex problem and we answer
it in a simple system well thank you for
teaching me about memory my pleasure
haha come back soon
so if I remember correctly the brain is
made up of cells called neurons and
these are connected via synapses and
messages are sent between them through
electrical signals and these messages
are often memories which are stored
within the neurons now what they
actually are physically we don't quite
know yet but if we did know we would
have a much better grasp on controlling
memory the problem in this kind of study
is that you actually need a living
subject because you need to be able to
look at whether it remembers something
before and after you manipulate it so
that's why we look at things like
transparent worms where we can actually
look at their brains while they're still
alive Thank You nature for creating
transparent worms and then scaled that
kind of information up to humans and I
am so excited about this kind of study
because we've seen how impactful
diseases like Alzheimer's or dementia
can be because really our memories are
so much of what make us us right now
here's a memory test for you do you
remember our video on string theory well
if not Garrett is right there you can
watch it again and strengthen all those
connections in your brain so you'll
remember forever
two for one
[Applause]
[Music]